buongiorno a tutti io ringrazio te dx
per l'invito che mi ha voluto estendere
io sono qua visto che tra poco sarà
l'ora di pranzo per parlarvi di qualcosa
di originale che ha a che fare con la
cucina e vorrei parlarvi della mia idea
per aprire le noci di cocco
allora noi tutti abbiamo in cucina
decine di attrezzi per tante tante
funzioni e quello che ci manca qualche
cosa per aprire noci di cocco quando
abbiamo questo problema bisogna andare
non in cucina ma a prendere la cassetta
degli attrezzi cercare un martello
cercare una sega o quant'altro oppure
andare a sbattere la
la notte sul pavimento contro un muro
quindi sono tutte pratiche non igieniche
faticose e spesso anche pericolose
soprattutto se usiamo una sega qualche
cosa di questo tipo
allora la mia idea è stata quella di
vedere che cos'è come è fatta una noce
di cocco è un seme che deve cadere dalla
palma queen da un'altezza tra i 25 30
metri senza rompersi ovviamente però
nonostante questo ha un punto debole che
è il punto da dove nasce la la gemma
della nuova palma quindi in natura da
uno dei tre cerchi che vediamo sul sul
guscio uscirà una gemma quando la notte
è matura e che darà origine a punto la
nuova palma solo uno dei tre cerchi e
attivo ed è chiamato il soft high in
inglese e per individuarlo andiamo a
semplicemente bussare diciamo su questi
tre allora il attrezzo che vi presento è
una co co crack una vite conica con
un'impugnatura e andando ad abitarlo in
uno in questo soft timing questo punto
debole
vediamo che cosa dovrebbe succedere
allora andiamo ad individuare appunto il
punto debole della noce quindi questo
soft high e cominciamo ad abitare la la
punta in acciaio ci si appoggia su una
superficie stabile per evitare di
perdere la noce insomma di fare dei
malanni ogni noce fa storia a sé quindi
io non so prevedere quanto come si come
si comporterà questa e altre due in caso
insomma abbiamo delle munizioni da
sparare
allora fino adesso io ho abitato con una
forza che è simile a quella che serve
per avvitare un cavatappi in un
nel tappo di sughero diciamo di una
bottiglia ora vado ad incontrare una
resistenza un po maggiore perché sono
arrivato a toccare il legno con con la
punta del blocco crack
a questo punto continua ad avvitare la
forma conica del della vite dovrebbe
fare questa non so se si è sentita
ecco il crack di cocco kakà
allora continuando ad abitare
eccolo andiamo ad avere una una crepa
sul guscio una 2 entra in questo caso
siamo anche stati fortunati
possiamo togliere l'acqua e recuperarla
per gli usi successivi insomma
continuando ad avvitare si staccano dei
pezzi di noce e ora questo pezzo vedete
è facile poi da staccare la polpa dal
guscio con un coltello da cucina
in questo caso invece dobbiamo andare a
utilizzare il secondo attrezzo che è una
specie di api scatole funziona come un
apriscatole inseriamo la la lama nel
nella polpa e andiamo a forzare quindi
anche qua si vanno a staccare dei pezzi
in successione fino a consentirci di
ottenere dei delle porzioni di cocco
sufficientemente piccole da
da staccare appunto rapidamente e
facilmente la porta ecco l'ultima fase
della dell'operazione prendere un
coltello da cucina e appunto infilarlo
tra il guscio e la polpa e a questo
punto riusciamo a ottenere i nostri
pezzi di cocco ecco questo grazie